what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have our second trailer for the
Marvels kind of our second trailer I say
that because I don't think this is the
last the Marvel's trailer that we're
going to be getting before the movie
comes out I do believe there is going to
be one more full official trailer I say
that because this trailer kind of is
partially a recap and kind of a what you
need to know about what happened in the
past to know what is happening with the
Marvels we have a recap of Carol Danvers
of Kamala Khan of Monica Rambo they put
out this trailer so you're not super
confused as to what is happening in the
marbles when you go to see it and of
course we'll break it all down and talk
about the things you need to know going
into the Marvels and what to expect
based off of this new footage that is
shown here in this trailer but first big
reminder today is the last day to enter
our giveaway of this month for a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
again we pick one winner each month and
the winner gets to pick one item only
one day left in August so be sure to
subscribe and leave a comment down below
so the first scene of this trailer is a
pretty epic scene we have Carol Danvers
flying through space but we have Goose
on her shoulder that you can see there
just chilling loving it just flying
through space his little flirkin self
helping out Captain Marvel defend the
universe so it looks like there is no
mistake at this point since we've seen
this and we've seen other footage of
goose with Captain Marvel goose is
Captain Marvel's cat a full-on travel
the universe together at this point but
then we hear Captain Marvel say I need
to regain the memories that the Creed
took from me and then we see a lot that
happened in the first Captain Marvel
film and we see a quick recap of her
life before the Creed took her we see
her as a pilot we see her with her best
friend Maria Rembo and we see her shoot
the Tesseract which in turn explodes and
gives her her powers from there the cree
taker eraser memory and eventually she
goes back down to earth thinking that
she is a Cree herself but ultimately
comes to the realization that she isn't
a Cree and she was abducted by them and
she breaks free of the Supreme
intelligence and ultimately feeds the
Supreme intelligence and then she goes
back on Earth talks to Maria Rambo talks
to her daughter Monica Rambo and
promises that she is going to be back
and of course she worked a lot with Nick
Fury as well becoming very close to him
so the biggest takeaway that you need to
know about Captain Marvel is that Maria
Rambo was her best friend and Maria's
daughter Monica was promised by Captain
Marvel that she would return and of
course Monica is going to be one of the
Marvels in this next movie and then we
cut to what happened to her during the
events of One Division unfortunately
when Captain Marvel was gone her friend
Maria and mother to Monica died then
Monica herself actually ended up getting
dusted she got blipped but then of
course she came back then she worked for
sword slash Shield she went to
investigate the anomaly that was
happening at West View and she went
through Wanda's protective barrier that
she had over Westview which gave her
powers and now she can manipulate
wavelengths of the electromagnetic
spectrum and then of course we have our
Miss Marvel kamalicon and here's where
we start to get into some really
important details we obviously know that
whenever Captain Marvel Kamala Khan or
Monica Rambo use their powers they
switch places so ultimately the three of
them end up in the same place on the
same ship most likely due to the fact
that they have to go out and solve why
they are switching places and to do that
they all have to be together Carol
Danvers can't go out into the universe
and keep switching places with somebody
on Earth or somewhere else so the three
of them have to be together and when
they get together Kamala Khan shows
Captain Marvel her bracelet and Captain
Marvel actually knows what it is and
questions Kamala about where she got it
and that's where we get a recap of Miss
Marvel now we know though that Miss
Marvel got sent in that Bengal from her
grandmother and we know that her family
actually got it from a dead cree and we
know that there was supposed to be two
but they only found one but we know the
cree had it which is probably why
Captain Marvel recognizes it and we also
know that darbin the villain of the
movie has the other Bengal so perhaps
Captain Marvel has actually ran into the
other Bengal before so once we get done
with all of the Recaps we see Captain
Marvel extend her hand to Kamala Khan
looking for a handshake basically saying
all right we're gonna do this we're
gonna be partners we're gonna go out
there figure out why we are switching
places but we're gonna be a team you me
and Monica the Marvels and I always feel
the need to address this because I think
it's hilarious they always play for the
marbles that is the Beastie Boys song
Intergalactic which starts with well now
don't you tell me to smile this goes
back to the first Captain Marvel for
when the promotions for it were
happening and people were all talking
about Brie Larson and how she didn't
smile and she needs to smile in which
she replied none of the other male
superheroes smile in their posters or
anything like that so I think this is a
super clever way to kind of take a jab
at that also the title of that song
Intergalactic is very fitting for this
movie since the three of them are going
to be exploring and searching the Galaxy
now from here they go on to talk more
about how they switch places every time
they use their powers and we do see Dar
Ben and we see that she is wearing the
other bangle she hits her Hammer that is
very similar to ronan's hammer Ronan the
Accuser from the first Guardians of the
Galaxy film who we believe she might
have some relation to but she hits the
hammer against her Bengal a huge
explosion goes off and something shoots
off into the sky and what we believe is
happening here is she is opening up
portals and she is going to be stealing
some planets resources we actually see
this a little bit in another trailer
that was released for the Marvels we saw
a different planet and a portal over the
ocean and water going into that portal
so she's either stealing resources for
herself or she is trying to destroy
other planets by taking their resources
but the interesting thing is we actually
see Cree on Earth and on Nick Fury's
ship on saber it looks like so it seems
like they are actually searching for the
other Bengal to give to darben and then
we have a final scene which shows us
what appears to be probably the final
fight of the movie the three of them
going up against our Ben and honestly
the action looks pretty dang good and if
you actually look very closely at the
end here at this battle they still are
swapping places Captain Marvel goes to
hit Darby man with her hammer it looks
like not using her power simply using a
weapon so she doesn't switch places with
anybody but then if you look in the back
Kamala Khan goes and shoots a beam at
her and as she shoots the beam she
actually begins to dissolve because she
is starting to switch places with one of
the others but this allows her to avoid
an attack from darbin so I definitely
think that they are going to be using
the fact that they are swapping places
with each other each time they use
powers as an advantage towards the end
of the movie this is going to be sort of
a battle tactic because imagine fighting
three people with powers who keep
switching places with each other every
time they use their powers it's
essentially the three of them
teleporting everywhere that's probably
going to be pretty hard to fight so I
definitely think they use that to their
advantage by the end of the film now one
thing I wanted to talk about real quick
is the run time of the Marvels according
to multiple inside sources the Marvels
is only going to be about 1 hour and 38
minutes long which is really short for a
Marvel movie but let's talk about why
this is because apparently they cut some
stuff and keep in mind the credits are
about five minutes long so the movie is
really about an hour and 33 minutes long
and according to some sources including
my time to shine hello they removed some
parts of the movie Mostly from the
musical planet that they visit we heard
about this long before we got the first
trailer for the Marvels that the Marvels
might be somewhat of a musical and a lot
of fans really did not like hearing that
but apparently the whole thing wasn't
going to be a musical they were simply
going to visit a planet that kind of
communicated musically and this was kind
of going to be the Musical part of the
movie well apparently they cut that out
they either realized that a lot of fans
probably didn't really want to see that
or they simply thought you know what
this doesn't work it's not very good
let's just cut it out of the movie so
that's probably a good thing if they
decided to cut it it probably wasn't
amazing so the movie is gonna be short
but hopefully what we do see in the film
is going to be pretty good again all the
action that we've seen in this so far in
the trailers looks pretty good and it
looks like it is is going to be pretty
funny as well fingers crossed but go
ahead and let us know your thoughts on
this new the Marvels trailer in the
comments down below are you excited for
the movie are you not excited let us
know all your thoughts and again don't
forget to subscribe and leave a comment
so you can enter our giveaway only one
day left and don't forget to follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign